vous saviez qu'il existait deux sortes
de lumière celle que l'on voit à
l'extérieur et celles qui se trouvent
dans votre coeur je vais vous raconter
comment j'ai appris à faire la
différence entre les deux je suis fier
mayans la luciole et je viendrai des
cardinaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette chose moi je vous dis
que c'est un objet mais elles auront
c'est pas pour me vanter mais je suis
c'est unique dans mon jeu c'est vrai la
lumière pourrait peut-être se déplacer
aussi
[Musique]
lui c'est trop bien vu que l'acte est
mince mais ce carnage
les fourmis ont été cambriolés hier soir
à lester bien né voici les aliments
qu'on a volé au village il nous faut
quelqu'un de courageux pour nous
protéger des assaillants
[Musique]
ne les laissez pas s'échapper
attention
[Musique]
m
les rois mais il a choisi sa date
d'anniversaire comme on le fait
[Musique]